Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Der McFi hat jetzt 'ne Cyber Partei gegründet. Wäre vielleicht was für die gestrandeten Piraten.
Ja ich ähm das ist jetzt echt geil, ne? Man kann vielleicht sollten wir auch ähm äh hier mal für Präsidentschaft in den USA kandidieren. Nicht immer nur meckern, sondern auch mal selber Scheiße bauen.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer einhundertzweiundfünfzig äh unter erschwerten Kommunikationsbedingungen hergestellt und äh produziert.
Also man kann, man muss jetzt sagen, es ist, glaube ich, die erste Folge Lokbuch-Netzpolitik, bei der,
Eines der beiden Geräte äh mit einem vertrauenswürdigen Kupfer oder Glasstück verbunden ist, was in irgendeiner Form eine Art Schein von Sicherheit geben könnte, dass diese Pakete auch wirklich ankommen.
Sehr genau oder so ankommen, wie sie es losgeschickt wurden.
Also wir befinden uns in einem in einem äh Hotel WLAN und kann man erzählen äh äh.
Und in einem LTE Tessering äh.
LTE, aber warum denn eigentlich Tim?
Ja, ja, ja. Ich habe hier gerade ein bisschen meinen Internetanschluss verkackt. Aber ist bald wieder.
Die Meterebene wird gerade abgewickelt.
Ja, einfach übergehender Zustand, äh, denke ich. Also, mit der, mit der Ankunft des Telekomtechnikers, wird das alles in Ordnung kommen.
Techniker ist informiert mit der mit dem Begleiten der Rechnung wird das alles wieder im.
Nee, das hat nichts mit Rechnung zu tun, ausnahmsweise mal.
Nee, ich weiß. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall, also ist ein echt guter Tipp, ähm wenn man sein äh seine DSL-Verträge und Telefonverträge einfach immer kündigt.
Dann kann man ja quasi sich neue Verträge machen zu günstigeren Tarifen oder die alten verlängern zu günstigeren Tarifen kann ich sehr empfehlen, ist nur eine Sache darf man nicht versauen,
Und das ist äh man muss einen Monat vor Kündigung äh dafür sorgen, dass man einen Anschlussvertrag hat.
Ja, das wäre von Vorteil. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Jetzt bohren bohren noch in der Wunde. Lass uns lieber zum äh Feedback kommen,
Es gab äh so einiges, wie immer. Und zwar zum,
Thema Wahlcomputerdiskussion, was jetzt schon ein paar Sendungen äh her ist, gab's nochmal den äh interessanten Hinweis von Hanno.
Äh fiel mir eine Bitte, nämlich äh sich doch bitte als Wahlhelfer zu engagieren, das hat der Hanno nämlich äh gemacht in Hamburg und wir hatten das Thema Hamburg ja auch
ähm Hinblick darauf, dass Hamburg ja vor einiger Zeit dieses Kumulieren und Passagieren eingeführt hat.
Man erinnert sich, da gab's ja dann den Plan, dass mit diesem geilen Wahlstift alles total digital, modern und zukunftskompatibel, schnell, mal innerhalb von einer Minute dann äh auszurechnen, damit man auch schön pünktlich
Wahlergebnisse veröffentlichen kann,
Nun wurde dieser Wahlstift äh aufgrund eklatanter Sicherheits und konzeptioneller äh Mängel unter anderem vom CCC dann auch äh vereitelt und es musste halt alles manuell ausgezählt werden. Hanno hat dann wohl an dieser ganzen Auszählung auch
teilgenommen und schlicht festgestellt, dass das alles eigentlich überhaupt gar kein Problem ist und dass die Leute auch mit dem äh komplexeren Auszählungssystem durchaus klar kamen.
Und ähm ja.
Natürlich gibt's dann in der Verwaltung und in der Politik immer noch Leute, die der Meinung sind, man müsste ja total modern und innovativ sein und irgendwie, oh Gott, das Ergebnis ist nicht um achtzehn Uhr eins schon fertig, aber ich glaube, das kann man alles mal getrost ignorieren,
verifizierbares System hat. Ja und Hanno meint äh,
Das hätte auch alles durchaus Spaß gemacht und äh letztlich wäre es vor allem auch wichtig, das zu tun, also sich als Wahlhelfer da einzubringen, damit man einfach alles im Blick hat und wenn dann die nächste dumme Idee kommt, dass man die dann eben auch schon
frühzeitig mit äh gewichtigen Argumenten widerlegen kann.
Ja, das haben wir dann hier mit äh diese Empfehlung geben wir einfach mal so äh trocken weiter.
Es schreibt, es es macht überraschenderweise tatsächlich Spaß, es ist sehr lehrreich. Das bisschen Arbeit mache ich mir auch die nächsten Jahre gern. Man lernt was über den Staat und vor allem über den eigenen Stadtteil.
Ja, genau, wahrscheinlich weil man einfach mal ein paar Leute auch kennenlernt, die man sonst wahrscheinlich so nie kennenlernen würde. Ersetzt also auch eine Datingbörse drin.
So Wahlhelfer in deiner Nähe wollen kumulieren und.
Ja, genau. Da sind wir dann dabei.
Äh
Ist die Sonne schon von Anfang an wieder albern. Oh Gott.
Ja, wir sind ja albern. Letzte Woche waren wir auch einmal ein bisschen zu albern, denn wir äh da habe ich einfach so, ne, gesagt, ähm
dass der Kurt Graulich ein Gastbeitrag bei Netzpolitik org geschrieben hat das stimmt aber nicht das steht natürlich auch groß drüber wir veröffentlichen den leicht gekürzten Beitrag mit freundlicher Genehmigung des Verlages. Zuerst erschien in
Vorgänge, Zeitschrift für Bürgerrechte und Gesellschaftspolitik. Ähm
Ausgabe zweihundertneun seit äh sechsundachtzig bis achtundneunzig. Ja, ähm das ist ein guter Hinweis, ähm den
bekommen haben.
Von von Jonas, genau. Also war falsch. Was wir da gesagt haben, nur äh Vorgänge, Zeitschrift für Bürgerrechte und Gesellschaftspolitik hat wahrscheinlich ähm nicht ganz so viele äh Leser wie,
Netzpolitik Org, deswegen.
Habe ich da mal die die äh die erreichbare Quelle genannt, weil das ist ja wahrscheinlich irgend so eine Wissenschaftszeitung, die wieder äh irgendwelchen Hardcore,
Zugangsrestriktion äh unterliegt vorbei, wenn sie's Netzpolitik org veröffentlicht haben, ist das wahrscheinlich eine bösartige Anschuldigung. Na ja, aber zum Inhalt hatten wir ja zwei Sachen.
Und zwar haben wir da letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, dass es ja einmal äh dass mir neu vorkommende Argument, dass es eine erzwungene Selbstbelast, dass die,
Locationspeicherung in Mobilfunknetzen quasi eine erzwungene Selbstbelastung sei
und dann das zweite Argument, äh wo es die Notwendigkeit äh äh des Gesetzes anging. Da habe ich dann äh haben wir auch festgestellt, dass wir keine Anwälte sind und äh uns regelmäßig bei,
juristischen Einschätzungen täuschen. Habe ich mal Ulf Buhrmeier gefragt, der sagt also, dieses Argument, der erzwungenen,
Selbstbelastung äh trägt nicht weit, weil die Selbstbelastung ja immer noch etwas ist, wo du dann ähm.
Aktiv vor Gericht dich darauf.
Berufen muss, zu sagen, hier und nicht weiter, ja? Und jeder andere beweist, der gegen dich erhoben wird, ist ja jetzt auch nicht eine erzwungene Selbstbelastung, also quasi äh wenn
Pistolen,
was weiß ich, Schmauchspuren an deinen Händen hinterlassen, dann ist ja der Verkauf von Pistolen, die Schmausspuren hinterlassen keine erzwungene Selbstbelastung, um da jetzt mal so einen richtig
schlechtes Beispiel zu nehmen, aber da sagt er also, das wird nicht besonders beitragen und als Strafrichter traue ich ihm da die Kompetenz zu diesen Sachverhalt,
äh korrekt zu erkennen. Gleich sagt er das mit dem mit der Notwendigkeit,
das würde wäre schon eher tragfähig, also sie sagt genau das Gegenteil von dem was ich letzte Woche gesagt habe.
Allerdings ist das auch irgendwie juristisch jetzt nicht am so wirklich sinnvoll äh umzusetzen. Da haben wir aber auch einen Kommentar von Alex bekommen,
auf dem Begriff der Verhältnismäßigkeit eingeht und sagt, Verhältnismäßig hat jede Rechtsnorm zu sein und das bedeutet, sie muss erstens einem legitimen Zweck dienen.
Zweitens, geeignet sein, diesen Zweck zumindest zu fördern.
Also man kann darüber nachdenken, an dieser Stelle mit der Prüfung schon aufzuhören, wenn es um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht, ja, wenn man sagt, äh sie ist nicht geeignet, diesen Zweck zu fördern, aber.
Ich glaube, dass dass sie theoretisch eine theoretische Eignung herbei theoretisieren kann. Das geringt Juristen dann schon,
Drittens, sie muss erforderlich sein und das ist an dieser Stelle definiert als es darf kein gleich geeignetes Mittel zur Erreichung des gleichen Zwecks zur Verfügung stehen, dass weniger stark in die betroffenen Rechte eingreift,
Und das ist, da kommt natürlich dann schon der Knackpunkt,
Äh und viertens, sie muss angemessen sein, das heißt, die Nachteile, die die Maßnahme mit sich bringt, dürfen mit dem angepeilten Zweck nicht völlig außer Verhältnis stehen. Also, legitimer Zweck, geeignet sein, diesen Zweck zu erfüllen.
Erforderlich sein und angemessen sein.
Ähm also erforderlich, um diesen Zweck zu erfüllen. Und äh gerade der letzte Punkt sagt, äh Alex, dann ist
bewusst derart schwammig gehalten, um im Einsatz im Einzelfall eine Abwägung der betroffenen Interessen zu ermöglichen, wo dann also äh
am Ende dann das äh Bundes der das äh äh.
Bundesverfassungsgericht. Jetzt wollte ich Bundesverwaltungsgericht sagen, das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagen kann, ja äh wir sehen jetzt am Ende
Voll Überwachung ist schlimmer als,
straff, äh, unterbliebene Strafverfolgung oder eben umgekehrt, ja, so dass am Ende eben ein Bundesverfassungsgericht stehen kann, was,
ein ein abwägen der Interessen im Sinne der äh Verfassung.
Dann äh durchführen kann,
ähm wirklich schlauer sind wir nicht. Gut nach wie vor das Kurt Graulich äh einer von uns ist, äh den wir jetzt äh in dem in dem BND-Keller äh eingeschlossen haben, auch wenn das wie sich.
Halt durch, Kurt.
Halt durch kopieren und kopieren, ja. Mach weiter und leg und leak und was nicht ist.
Ja, gib alles.
Der ist ja jetzt eh schon verdächtig. Ich meine, der hat ja mindestens einen E-Mail-Kontakt mit mit Netzpolitik org gehabt, also,
dass sie den noch da reinlassen, halte ich für unwahrscheinlich.
Oder rauslassen.
Oder ne, vielleicht auch nicht. Vielleicht haben die ja wirklich nur beim Verlag gefragt. Ähm na ja,
Dann wurde ich noch in den Kommentaren gefragt gebeten zu kommentieren dass er jetzt bei United Internet.
PGP möglich ist. Das war irgendwie so eine so eine Werbemeldung äh in der vergangenen Woche. Ähm.
Die die sagen also jetzt ja hier äh bei bei uns gibt's jetzt hier äh PGP. Ja und ähm,
Was sie dann nutzen, ist das Plug-in browser Plugin von Thomas Obernörfer, den ich auch kenne, habe ich,
schon mal erwähnt, ähm der da seit langer Zeit ähm an diesem Plug-in entwickelt. Ich würde mal schätzen, der ist mindestens seit drei, vier Jahren daran,
dieses Projekt jetzt für ihn laufen? Und die das Projekt ist aus den,
Aus der Notwendigkeit herausgeboren, dass eben so viele Menschen webmälern nutzen. Und ähm man kann jetzt hier irgendwie so sagen, als PGP-Nutzer sagt man dann so, ja, äh ne, einfach, gibt ja für für alle gängigen äh,
ähm Mail-User-Agents irgendwie Plug-ins, also gibt einen Plug-in, gibt ein Apple-Mail, Plug-in, gibt ein Outlook-Plug-in
gibt ein Mut-Plug-in so und was gibt's noch? Irgendwie für die meisten
anderen äh großen äh Mail-Programme gibt's ja auch Plug-Ins. Und dann sagt man ja immer so installierst du dir einfach so, aber die das
das Hindernis bei der Verbreitung von PTP ist ja inzwischen auch, dass äh die meisten Leute eben gar keine ähm,
Mail-Programme nutzen, sondern eben Weboberflächen. Und da hat der ähm Thomas eben.
Schon vor einigen Jahren äh erkannt, dass das eben äh.
Heißt, dass er im Prinzip ein Plug-in für den Browser bauen muss. Und ähm.
Das ist äh durchaus äh positiv zu sehen seine Arbeit da. Ich äh das ist natürlich auch äh positiv zu sehen, wenn ähm,
E-Mail Provider, dass dann auch noch,
weiter in ihre Oberflächen integrieren äh und zur Anwendung bringen und bewerben. Wobei sie da natürlich am Ende nicht das Plug-in bewerben, sondern sich selber,
und ähm das ja sehe ich dann äh wohlwollend, ja. Ich meine, jede PGP Mail, die mehr geschrieben wird, ist halt,
positiv zu betrachten, auf in meine Präferenz ja inzwischen eigentlich eher bei ähm S-Meim liegt.
Und ähm dann gleichzeitig wurde aber auch dieses Plug-in war dahinter als äh bei D-Meldern groß äh geschrieben wurde. Ja, Demel jetzt endet zu Ende verschlüsselt und so, ne? Und die Kritikpunkte bleiben natürlich
Dass es irgendwie optional ist und ähm dass es eben etwas.
Im Nachhinein drauf geflanschtes ist und ähm da kann man jetzt den E-Mail Provider ein wenig äh,
wenig Vorwurf machen so, aber es wäre natürlich irgendwie spannend gewesen, wenn sie mal so den
Schritt gewagt hätten so zu sagen, okay, jeder, der sich jetzt hier noch, der sich hier einloggt, der kriegt jetzt sofort Kies und so und das erzwingen wir jetzt einfach mal und äh wir wir versuchen, wir verschicken keine äh
nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselten E-Mails mehr, wenn es an die wenn am, wenn wir wissen, dass am anderen Ende auch ein Kiel lauert und so, da könnte man könnte man noch viel
stärker rangehen. Insofern ist das natürlich eher leider äh hier halbherzig und äh so eine Marketingmaßnahme und ähm.
Bei bei ähm D-Mail war's eben einfach nur noch peinlich, weil sie sich ja so lange dagegen gewehrt haben, äh das überhaupt zu machen. Und das war dann eben schon sehr äh,
ärgerlich, welche auch die eben davor gewarnt haben und gesagt haben so, ey Freunde, jetzt habt ihr die einmalige Gelegenheit, das mal ordentlich zu machen und ähm,
quasi Plantex Kommunikation einfach gar nicht zuzulassen. Und das ist entsprechende Messaging Systeme gibt, ist ja äh,
offenbar äh und offenkundig äh zum Beispiel eben, was weiß ich, wenn du so äh ähm Threema nimmst, die eben,
das so gemacht haben, dass dein Kiefinger-Print eben.
Direkt mit dem mit deinem Account und mit deiner Identity quasi alles eins ist, ja? Ähm,
Und das geht ja mit jedem äh asymmetrischen Verschlüsselungssystem, das du im Prinzip sagst, okay, äh ich schreibe an eine Key ID und dann brauchst du eigentlich nur noch was da dran zu pflanzen, was eben nach Key IDs Messages zustellt. Ähm und dann hast du ein schönes System. Und das war ja auch das, wofür ich damals versucht habe zu argumentieren
aber.
Aber dir hört ja keiner zu, ne, Linus.
Mir hört keiner zu.
Nee, warum auch?
Wir haben ja keine Ahnung. Kriegen wir ja oft genug gesagt. Da da war ja auch mein mein flaxiger Kommentar in der letzten Sendung, äh wenn wir auf äh,
und wir gesagt, wenn uns wieder mal erklärt wird, dass wir ja nur Unsinn reden, was ich mir ja wünsche, ist, dass mir dann auch gesagt wird, was, damit ich den äh Fehler in der folgenden Sendung spätestens dann wenigstens mal korrigieren kann.
Da freue ich mich dann immer.
Tja, das war's eigentlich an äh Feedback, oder?
Ja, ich denke schon. Also es kamen natürlich noch mehr Feedback, aber das das erwähnenswerte, wir müssen etwas ergänzen oder korrigieren, Feedback haben wir hoffentlich damit abgehandelt.
Das denke ich auch. Gut, machen wir weiter mit äh Landesverrat, die unendliche äh Geschichte. Jetzt geht's an die Aufarbeitung. Und äh ja, es es gab etwas Akteneinsicht.
Genau ähm Markus und Andre haben mir oder die Anwälte von Markus und Andre haben jetzt äh Einsicht in die Akten. Ähm.
Müssen wir eigentlich, müssen wir eigentlich die vollen äh Namen äh nennen. Wir sitzen immer so alle voraus, dass das hier irgendwie bei Markus und André immer klar ist, wer gemeint ist.
Markus Beckerdal und Andre Meister.
Politik Org.
Ja muss man vielleicht sagen so hört alles ab, Folge hundert wann war das?
Eins.
Wann hat Landesverrat angefangen.
Ähm.
Hunderteins? Nee.
Nein, nein, äh.
Den Auftakt hat ja die Sendung, also wenn man jetzt in Lokbuch-Netzpolitik Rechnungen, äh Sendungen rechnet, äh war ja die, wo,
Markus, wo ich mit Markus und Andre darüber gesprochen habe. Na ja, guck mal hier, ist gar nicht so lange her. LNP eins vier neun.
Hundertvierhundertneunundvierzig. Äh ach genau, dann war die längere Pause wegen Camp. Also hundertneunundvierzig Landesverrat äh äh für diejenigen, die äh nicht wissen, worum's geht.
Ähm und in der letzten Sendung hatten wir auch schon darüber gesprochen,
Anwälte brauchen jetzt Akteneinsicht, das ist äh normal, wenn man Beschuldigter ist, so kann man eben Akteneinsicht äh verlangen. So und die haben da jetzt so ein bisschen drin gestöbert und dann daraus ähm,
mal erzählt. Und äh es sieht also so aus, dass die ursprüngliche Anzeige des ähm.
Verfassungsschutz Maaßen ging ja an das Landeskriminalamt Berlin.
Und äh von denen findet sich also in den Akten kaum etwas. Die haben kaum eigene Recherchen unternommen, sondern den Fall mal lieber sofort zum Generalbundesanwalt weiter geschoben, das ja auch in Ordnung. Ähm.
Gleichzeitig haben sie dann den Eindruck, dass in den Akten dass die Akten nicht vollständig sind, denn es gibt kaum Vermerke über den Inhalt von,
Telefonaten und nahezu keine E-Mails. Und üblicherweise arbeiten Behörden halt so, dass sie dann eben, ne, vermerkt, ich habe telefoniert oder hier E-Mail geschrieben und die sind eben alle nicht da drin. Also haben sie den Eindruck,
den nichtbelegbaren Eindruck, dass in diesen Akten dass dieser Akten einer,
Reinigung unternommen wurden, aber das ist natürlich einfach nur ein subjektiver Eindruck, den man da als Anwalt hat, kann ja auch gut sein, dass sie einfach nicht telefoniert haben und keine E-Mails geschrieben haben oder nahezu keine E-Mails geschrieben haben.
Ja oder keine Vermerker gemacht haben über ihre Telefonate und ihre E-Mails.
Genau, das kann auch sein. Und äh aber vielleicht haben die auch tatsächlich nicht telefoniert und E-Mails geschrieben, weil die ja wissen, dass das alles abgehört wird.
Ja, Überwachung könnte nämlich auch die Tätigkeit einer Regierung nachdrücklich äh einschränken.
Ach du bist, ich wollte eher äh erinnere mich dran, nachher noch ein bisschen von der vom elften Geburtstag von Netzpolitik org zu schwärmen. Aber jetzt erst mal hier weiter. Ähm.
Interessant war ja dann, welche Maßnahmen wurden denn gegen die beiden Beschuldigten ergriffen? Und äh,
da gab's also die Abfrage von von Kugel und den Daten des Einwohnermeldeamtes, dann haben sie,
Auskunft bei der Deutschen Rentenversicherung über den Arbeitgeber eingeholt.
Natürlich in dem Fall einfach. Ähm Auskunft bei der Bundesanstalt für Finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht, also der sogenannten BaFin, wo sie dann eine detaillierte Liste der Bankkonten bekommen haben.
Und äh ob Servation oder Überwachungsmaßnahmen gehen aus den Daten nicht hervor.
Und das heißt, dass eine solche stattgefunden haben durch
Maßnahmen durch Polizeibehörden stattgefunden haben, ist demnach unwahrscheinlich. Also Polizeibehörden werden in dem Fall eben das
BKA oder LKA Berlin,
hätte jetzt das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz oder andere Dienste derartige Maßnahmen ergriffen, dann äh stünden die äh nicht in solchen Akten, denn wir kennen uns ja die gängige Praxis, ist ja äh die Geheimdienst,
Die Rechtslage ist Geheimdienste dürfen dich äh ohne äh deine äh Informationen oder so ähm überwachen.
Deren Erkenntnisse dürfen aber eben nicht zu deiner Strafverfolgung genutzt werden und Strafverfolgungsbehörden dürfen.
Beweise sammeln, die äh vor Gericht verwendet werden, die dürfen dich aber nicht äh einfach ohne richterliche Anordnung überwachen,
Äh und der der sich daraus ergebende kurze Dienstweg ist eben, dass äh die Geheimdienste Strafverfolgungsbehörden in Kenntnis setzen und den dann helfen
durch Zufall einen Anfangsverdacht zu bekommen, mit dem sie dann irgendwie einen richterlichen Schluss äh Beschluss bekommen oder so. Ähm.
Dann hat sich in den Akten gefunden, dass äh Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutzgutachten von Herrn Müller.
Das ist also das äh das äh Gutachten, was dann beigelegt wurde ähm.
Um den Vorwurf des Landesverrates hier zu erhärten, also das war das Gutachten, was dann eben dem Range vorgelegt wurde und jenes Gutachten, äh wo der Range dann eben auch sagte, ähm,
das reicht mir jetzt nicht, aber bleiben wir erstmal bei diesem. Dieses Gutachten kommt zu dem Ergebnis, ähm dass es,
um Staatsgeheimnisse ginge, die da veröffentlicht wurden. Da steht aber nicht drin, dass es sich bei der Veröffentlichung dieser Staatsgeheimnisse auch um Landesverrat handle. Vielmehr wird äh übermittelt, dass der Vorwurf des Landesverrates,
dass das Wort Landesverrat mehr oder weniger in dem Gutachten nicht äh nicht vorkommt, weil der Vorwurf eben nicht besprochen wird. Ähm stattdessen scheint dieses Gutachten hauptsächlich zu argumentieren, dass.
Ähm.
Die Veröffentlichung hilft, Nutzung von Verschlüsselung und äh Verschleierung von Kommunikation zu unterstützen und dadurch eben das ähm.
Die Arbeit von Geheimdiensten zu stören, so, ja, also,
Auf Basis dieses Gutachtens hat dann der äh gute Herr Range das Verfahren ohne Verzögern eröffnet und hat sich dann ähm,
nochmal ein internes Gutachten geben lassen.
Wo der der oder die Autorin argumentiert, dass man tatsächlich Anhaltspunkte für Staatsgeheimnisse sehe. Ähm.
Und auch eine konkrete Gefahr, eine schwere Nachteils für die äußere Sicherheit der Bundesrepublik, ja, weil jetzt die Leute wissen, äh wie wie die geheimdienstliche Überwachung von Kommunikationswegen aufgestellt ist.
Und dann hat aber der Rang ja, wie gesagt, sich noch ein externes Gutachten einholen wollen. Ähm das war auch dieses, auf das dann zu warten war und durch die Akteneinsicht wurde jetzt der,
Name dieses externen Gutachters bekannt. Und zwar ist das der Herr Professor Doktor Jan Hendrik Dietrich, neununddreißig Jahre alt
und der verfügt über einen Dienstausweis des Bundesnachrichtendienstes,
weil, weil, weil, weil, weil, also,
diese Witzsekunde darf man sich natürlich dann nicht entgehen lassen, aber weil er Professor an der Fachhochschule des Bundes für öffentliche Verwaltung in haar bei München ist, im Fachbereich Nachricht Nachrichtendienst.
Ähm das heißt, der.
Aha.
Angehörige des BND, also äh.
Die äh es gibt ja dann auch für Polizisten gibt's ja dann auch eigene Fachhochschulen, ne, dann gehen die auf den Polizeifachhochschule, werden da werden da dann äh Polizist, höheren Dienst oder sowas, ähm
Und so was gibt's eben auch für einen BND, ja? Und äh er unterrichtet eben Angehörige des BND und ähm,
hat eben auch so eine äh Security Clearence, um hocheingestufte Informationen zu lesen. Und,
meine vorsichtige Einschätzung äh ist hier, dass das natürlich, ist das ein Schenkelklopfer, dass das dass der Typ ein BND-Dienstausweis hat. Ähm.
Gleichzeitig musste der äh Ranne wahrscheinlich schon äh.
Aufgrund der behördlichen äh Vorgaben jemanden finden, der ihm dieses Gutachten schreibt, der eben auch äh,
hat, also berechtigt ist hocheingestufte Informationen zu lesen, weil wenn der Verdacht im Raum ist, dass wir hier mit hocheingestuften Informationen zu tun haben und Landesverrat und so, dann braucht er natürlich jemanden,
der da einerseits in Nachrichtendienst, Recht und sowas Ahnung hat ähm.
Verwaltungsrecht und so. Und zweitens, nach Möglichkeit so eine Clearince, insofern halt die Wahl auf diesen ähm auf diese Person. Aber dann natürlich die Frage, die uns alle äh eigentlich am meisten sorgt, ist die, hat denn der.
Der Generalbundesanwalt 'ne 'ne nennenswerte realistische Chance nochmal auf die Quelle zu kommen ja?
Und äh da äh scheint es eben in den Akten so zu sein, dass nach einer vorläufigen Auswertung ähm.
Im ersten der der beiden angeblichen Landesverratsfälle
hundertfünfundzwanzig Mitarbeiter des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz Zugriff und in dem anderen Fall mindestens einhundertneununddreißig Beamte theoretischen Zugang zu den,
Dokumenten. Und daher könnte der tatsächliche Kreis derer die Unterlagen erhalten haben könnten.
Nicht genau bestimmt werden.
Ist aber doof.
Und das waren dann so die die neuen Seiten, die die Ermittlungen des BKA hier irgendwie produzieren konnten.
Sehe ich das? Sehe ich das denn äh äh richtig, dass sozusagen das ursprüngliche Gutachten vom Verfassungsschutz letzten Endes äh
als einzigen wirklichen Vorwurf äh anzuführen hat, dass die Berichterstattung äh dabei hilft, die Nutzung von Verschlüsselung und Verschleierung zu unterstützen,
Das war's.
So so ist es hier überliefert, ja, dass er Oberwitz ist, dass dieses äh Verfahren, äh dass dieses Gutachten eben offenbar nicht.
Geschrieben hat, das hier ist Landesfahrrad Weil.
Sondern das Amt legt da, wie die Berichterstattung von Netzpolitik org dabei hilft, die Nutzung von Verschlüssung, Verschleierung der Kommunikation zu unterstützen.
Also dann sind wir ja im Prinzip auch schon fast Landesverräter sozusagen. Potenziell.
Ja, ja, also gut, das sind wir, wir sind ja alle Landesverräter. Aber äh.
Ja, also.
Okay, aber wie gesagt, also da dieses Gutachten, der der Gag ist schon, dass äh.
Also nee, sind wir eben nicht, weil dieses Gutachten ja eben nicht sich auf Landesverrat bezieht.
Sondern also Landesverrat scheint, ich hab's jetzt nicht gesehen, ja, aber so nach dem, was ich bei Netzpolitik, Org und bei äh süddeutsche äh Zeitung lese, ähm.
Hat dieses Gutachten einen Landesverrat nicht zum Thema.
Na ja gut, aber es führte ja dann letzten Endes zu diesem Vorwurf, also muss sozusagen jeder, der sozusagen die Nutzung von Verschlüsselungen, Verschleierung unterstützt, potenziell damit rechnen, als Landesverräter angeklagt zu werden.
Nee, nicht angeklagt zu werden.
Ermittlungen aufgenommen werden.
Genau, also das offenbar schon. Also das reicht offenbar hat unserem in Ruhestand äh geschobenen Generalbundesanwalt offenbar ausgereicht, um ähm.
Zumindest äh ein Ermittlungsverfahren zu eröffnen. Wie gesagt, der äh Schenkelklopfer der Geschichte ist ja dann eben auch was für ermittlungsverfahren. Dieser Mann alles nicht eröffnet hat.
Ja
Ja, was willst du dazu sagen?
Da sagen wir jetzt mal nix zu.
Bin mal gespannt, wie sich das dann noch weiter entwickelt.
Ja, kommen wir zur ähm Geschichte um Glutai herum. Überwachungsgeschichte, die ewige Fortsetzung.
Da ging es um das Abhören,
durch die CIA, also abhören deutscher Telekommunikationen mit Hilfe des BND. Und zwar verhielt es sich so, dass zwischen zweitausendvier und zweitausendsechs.
Telefon und Faxverkehre, die über den US-Anbieter MCI, an dessen deutschen Standort in Hilden abgehandelt wurden.
Zugriff bestand. Und nach Arbeitsauftrag des BND kann da ja.
Dürfen da ja nur ähm Auslandsverkehre.
Abgehört werden und die wurden dann äh mit dem äh BND äh,
ähm durch den BND mit der CIA äh getauscht. Und der Ermittlungsstand des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses ist, alle Gespräche, die mit der CIA getauscht wurden.
Die der CIA weitergereicht wurden, seien vom BND gefiltert und geprüft worden.
Und jetzt gibt es aber ein BND-Papier, vor sich rausstellt, die Audiodaten abgehörter Gespräche,
wurden direkt nach USA geroutet, damit die Audiofunktion ohne Aussetzer funktioniert. Ja, also,
NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss behauptet wurde, ist schon mal falsch, denn aus technischen Gründen wurden diese abgehörten Gespräche direkt
nach USA geroutet, damit's keine Aussetzer gibt. Was auch immer die da meinen, mit Aussetzern, also ich man kann sehr wohl ein mitgeschnittenes Gespräch
speichern, anhören und dann an die USA schicken. Aber vermutlich meinen die hier mit Aussetzer, die Verzögerung zwischen Gespräch findet, findet statt und,
USA hören's ab. Ja, ähm und dann gab's noch eine Panne ähm.
Gab's eine Panne, denn äh durch eine Panne haben sie ähm auch Deutsche äh Kommunikation abgehört.
Das war aber eine Panne. Ja, Panne. Haben sie sich vertan? Äh und dann gibt's also mit anderen Worten, deutsche Gespräche, äh live,
direkt in die USA geroutet, damit die Audiofunktion ohne Aussetzer funktioniert, wo uns erzählt wurde, es wäre gefiltert worden und äh äh,
natürlich Deutsche nicht übertragen worden. Und dann war Ermittlungstand des NSA Untersuchungsausschuss. Der BND habe für die gemeinsame Operation, also Glothaik,
von der CIA keine Technik erhalten.
Ähm es gibt aber einen schriftlichen Vermerk, in dem äh Rechner erwähnt werden, die den Deutschen von der CSA zur von der,
CIA äh zur Verfügung gestellt wurden, ja? Also es wurde gesagt, uns wurde gesagt, wir haben keine Technik von der CIA bekommen,
Stimmt nicht. Uns wurde gesagt, es war gefiltert und geprüft, stimmt nicht. Uns wird gesagt, äh es wurden keine Deutschen äh abgehört. Stimmt nicht.
Und diese Maßnahme hat aber dann ein Ende gefunden, zweitausendsechs, weil man sich beim BND intern vor einem politischen Skandal warnte, wenn das Ganze mal auffliegt.
Ähm.
Könnte ja zum Beispiel auffliegen, dass die gesamte Operation,
nicht durch das G zehn Gesetz gedeckt gewesen war, äh dass die Beschränkung des Fernmeldegeheimnisses regelt und außerdem eben auch deutsche abgehört wurden. Also so einmal gegen alle Regeln vollständig äh verstoßen und ähm ja.
Da haben sie dann irgendwann gedacht so, oh krass, wenn dat mal auffliegt, dann äh sind wir rollen hier aber die Köpfe. Völlig unbegründet begründete Sorge.
Heute nix.
Denn äh ja, ja.
Im Stammblatt vom April zweitausendacht schreiben die Verfasser von schwerwiegenden Risiken für den Nachrichtendienst. Äh sollte zum Beispiel bekannt werden. Ja ähm also die waren sich auch.
Ihrer Missetaten da vollständig bewusst.
Also so würde ich das dann sehen, ne? Wenn jemand, wenn du interne Vermerker hast, wo die sagen, ey Alter, wenn das rauskommt, sind wir dran, äh dann kannst du halt auch nicht mehr von einer Panne reden.
Sondern von sehr, aber es war natürlich alles.
Eine Verschleierungspanne.
Ich konnte dich jetzt leider nicht hören, Tim.
Ich sage dir, das ist eine Verschleierungspanne.
Ja, Verschleierungsplane hast du gesagt, ne? Ja, du baust echt mal einen besseren LTE-Fahr.
Du brauchst mal ein besseres Hotel WLAN.
Ey, dieses Hotel WLAN hier ist Trusted, das haben wir schon so oft benutzt. Na ja, egal. Ähm.
Bei LTE auch.
Aber nicht für Podcasts.
Podcast. Los, weiter.
Aber was soll ich dir sagen, Tim, es wird ja alles.
Es wird ja alles besser, weil jetzt wird's ja bald ein Datenschutzabkommen, ja, es wird bald ein Datenschutzabkommen zwischen EU und.
Hey, ja.
Das ist doch echt mal eine Überschrift, wo man denkt so, oh krass, super, hey, spannend. Äh bin ich ja mal gespannt, was da drin steht. Ähm ja, Hintergrund ist, ähm, die sind da eigentlich schon seit zweitausendzehn dran,
irgendwie so ein Datenschutzabkommen hinzukriegen. Das ist also seit zweitausendzehn in der Mache, weil,
ja? Wir erinnern uns von den USA wurde uns mehr oder weniger aufoktroiert, der Austausch von Bankdaten im Swift-Abkommen.
Und die Übertragung von äh Flugpassagierdaten, den PMPNR-Abkommen, Passengerecord, ja? Ähm.
Und in dem PNR-Abkommen geht's ja
eben darum, dass die USA man verschleiert das so als PNR-Kommer, im Prinzip heißt das, die wollen halt wissen, wer in den äh in den Flugzeugen sitzt und zwar nicht zu knapp.
Ähm von denen wollen die eben alles haben, nämlich die Passengers, das ist das, was die äh Fluglinien dann alle äh die Airlines so alles über ihre Kunden haben in dem PNR-Profil. So und im
Beides haben wir hier auch bei Logbuch Netzpolitik Barnett, gibt's nicht viel Neues zu,
Aber in diesen Abkommen haben die USA bestimmte Garantien gegeben, was die Datenverarbeitung angeht und.
Es gab aber keine rechtlichen, kein rechtlichen Rahmen, in dem man sich diese Garantien vor US-Gerichten,
einklagen können. Ja? Und das heißt.
Wir brauchten jetzt einen Datenschutzabkommen, um diese ähm Strafverfolgungsbehörden zusammenarbeit vom Datenaustausch in großem Stil.
Einerseits in einen rechtlichen Rahmen zu stecken und gleichzeitig sicherzustellen, dass sie im Prinzip ähm.
Dem so sind, dass wir als EU-Bürger der Bürger, als EU-Bürger, der.
Deren Daten, deren Daten in die USA geliefert werden, ähm die Möglichkeit haben,
überhaupt irgendwie unsere Rechte dort vor den Gerichten geltend zu machen. Ja und dafür soll's jetzt dieses Datenschutzabkommen geben.
Ja, was ja total attraktiv ist.
Also auf jeden Fall mit diesem Datenschutzabkommen soll eben jetzt klargestellt werden, dass wir da einen Rechtsrahmen haben. Und ähm.
In den USA müssen muss dann jetzt bald ein Gesetz eingeführt werden, dass es EU-Bürgern ermöglicht, ihre Datenschutzrechte vor EU
US-Gerichten durchzusetzen. Das klingt natürlich erstmal spannend, weil da wäre ja so diese gesamte Wirtschaft äh wäre da ja völlig mit äh äh Durcheinander ähm.
Geworfen. Stellt euch mal vor, äh als EU-Bürger könnten wir jetzt Datenschutzrechte, die wir haben, vor US-Gerichten gegenüber.
Ähm,
US-Anbietern geltend machen, ne? Dann könnten wir also jetzt hier europäischen Datenschutz gegenüber Facebook durchsetzen, vor US-Gerichten. Genau deshalb äh betrifft dieses Datenschutzabkommen auch diese Bereiche nicht, denn
das ist ja geregelt durch das Abkommen.
Von dem äh bei dem das äh EU-Parlament der EU-Kommission ja ohnehin ähm.
Empfiehlt es aufzukündigen, ja?
Aber genau dieser Bereich, den eben safe Haber betrifft, ist davon nicht betroffen. Und ähm dieses Datenschutzabkommen
dessen Text jetzt heute äh fertiggestellt wurde, ähm wurde selbstverständlich wie so oft in äh derartigen Abkommen äh hinter verschlossenen Türen ausgehandelt. Und das heißt, den Text ähm.
Habe ich zumindest noch nicht vorliegen. Und deswegen können wir den den Inhalt dieses Abkommens jetzt auch nicht ähm,
Abschließend bewerten und können uns dann nur den Worten.
Der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten Andrea Vosshoff äh anschließen, die sagt, dass grundsätzliche Verbot der Weitergabe von Daten an in Drittstaaten begrüße ich. Das ist also Teil davon, dass da jetzt steht.
Die USA dürfen diese Daten nicht noch mal weiter an Drittstaaten geben, wo die schon mal cool äh auch die Tatsache, dass EU-Bürger ein Klagerecht in den USA eingeräumt wird, ist ein zentraler Punkt, den äh Andrea Vossow explizit gefordert hat.
Aber auch viele vor ihr, wie gesagt, die Debatte läuft seit zweitausendzehn. Die erzielte ein.
Einigung kann aber nur ein Erster, wenn auch richtungsweisender Schritt auf dem Weg zu mehr Datenschutz für europäische Bürger in den USA sein.
Neben dem Rahmenabkommen für den Bereich der Strafverfolgung halte ich es eben für ebenso wichtig, dass der Datenschutz für alltägliche Datenübermittlung im privaten und wirtschaftlichen Bereich verbessert wird,
das ist eben das, was ich gerade sagte, äh safe habe. Ähm daher hoffe ich, dass die bereits mehrere Jahre andauernden Verhandlungen zwischen der EU und den USA zum Thema Safe haben,
ebenfalls zeitnah zu einem erfolgreichen Abschluss gebracht werden. Die finden nämlich auch gerade statt. Also äh nicht verwirren lassen durch,
wir können jetzt bald unsere Datenschutzrechte vor US-Gerichten einklagen. Das gilt also nur für diese
seit fünf Jahren stattfindenden Austausch äh über unsere Finanztransaktionen und unsere Flugbewegungen, ja.
Und äh was wir jetzt gewonnen haben ist, okay, die USA geben das nicht. Wir dürfen das jetzt nicht einfach in Drittstaaten weitergeben, äh was unsere äh Regierung in da über uns verraten.
Ja, was, was, was soll man dazu äh noch sagen? Also es ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich äh offensichtlich, dass hier nicht wirklich ein Interesse daran besteht, äh wirklich einen Datenschutz zu etablieren, sondern einfach nur äh sich soweit rauszuwinden, wie's irgendwie geht, um halt diese ganzen
Begehrlichkeiten zu bedienen.
Der eigentliche, der eigentlich schöne Teil wäre gewesen, wenn man jetzt dieses PNR- und Swift-Abkommen einfach mal zack aufgekündigt hätte. Äh da so hätte man das Problem ähm auch löst.
Ja, aber da ist dann halt noch nicht der passende politische Wille in der EU vorhanden, obwohl sie sich alle so dermaßen aufgeregt haben über all diese ganze Überwachung und das ging ja irgendwie gar nicht. Ist ja alles noch mal vor dem Prüfstand stellen, aber
Prüfstand, der funktioniert irgendwie noch nicht so richtig.
Kommen wir äh zu einem anderen äh Thema, der auf mehreren äh Ebenen ganz interessant ist. Ähm jetzt geht's um.
Zwang, der, na ja, droht, beziehungsweise in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon auf dem Weg ist,
klassischer Fall von hätte man das mal früher bemerkt. Die ganze Story begann dadurch, dass wohl der
Die IFF, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wer der ursprünglich drauf hingewiesen hat, aber es wurde, es wurde sozusagen bekannt, dass es äh einen Plan der FCC äh äh gibt, sogenannte ARF-Devices, also funkende Geräte
ähm
so absichern zu lassen, dass man dort keine alternative Firmware aufspielen äh kann mehr. Äh Hintergrund ist hier eine Absicherung des Funkverhaltens. Konkret sorgt man sich hier äh vor allem wohl um den fünf Gigahertz-Bereich
und es stellte sich dann auch heraus
dass es äh eine entsprechende Vereinbarung für WLAN-Rauter wohl auch tatsächlich schon äh gibt und die in USA und in Kanada auch schon,
in Kraft sind. Das hat dann hier großes Interesse,
erzeugt natürlich in Europa, weil man so ein bisschen befürchtet hat, dass so etwas natürlich dann auch schnell wieder nach Europa rüber schwappert und stellt sie sich heraus, surprise, surprise, das ist hier auch schon äh eine
verabschiedete äh Richtlinie ist es, glaube ich, ähm äh gibt in der EU.
Und äh dass das Ganze äh im Juni zwanzig sechzehn dann äh auch schon Realität werden soll.
Das ist äh natürlich insofern jetzt ein äh Thema, als dass das eben so Projekte wie Freifunk zum Beispiel, unmittelbar betrifft und es gibt natürlich auch sonst viele Leute. Äh sonst viele Leute, die,
einfach WLAN, Hardware kaufen und mit ihrer eigenen Software bestücken. Ähm da ist dann halt zum Beispiel Open WRT zu nennen, was wir hier schon äh häufiger
angesprochen haben oder auch konkret, dass DD WRT.
Eins in Dresden gestartete äh Projekt, was äh auch sozusagen am selben Feld äh ackert.
Ja und nun steht zu befürchten, dass ähm wir eine Richtlinie bekommen, die dann eben auch äh,
in nationales Gesetz umgesetzt werden müsste, die schlicht verhindern soll, dass man diesen Geräten eine,
Eigene Firmware aufspielt, die das sozusagen strafbar macht beziehungsweise die Geräte müssen verhindern, dass es möglich ist.
Sich natürlich lange, kann man sich lange darüber unterhalten. Ähm ob das überhaupt,
verhinderbar ist auf jeden Fall, kann es deutlich erschwert werden.
Also das ähm die EU-Richtlinie, von der da die Rede ist, ist die EU-Richtlinie zweitausendvierzehn Schrägstrich dreiundfünfzig Schrägstrich EU. Äh die wurde zweitausendvierzehn unbemerkt beschlossen.
Und wird jetzt Juni zweitausendsechzehn in Kraft treten und.
Jetzt müssen wir uns mal vielleicht noch kurz erklären, was soll das eigentlich, ja? Also ähm das Ziel dieser Richtlinie ist,
die Vorschriften über Frequenzen, Nutzung, Sendeleistung und Modulation eingehalten werden. Also du kannst äh ne, auf welcher Frequenz,
du WLAN
zwei Komma vier Gigahertz und fünf Gigahertz betreiben darfst, auf welchen Frequenzen. Das ist klar definiert und entsprechende Kanäle gibt es und entsprechend ist ähm
Hardware auch konfiguriert. Und ähm die du kaufst, ja? Denn du kannst zum Beispiel.
Ähm habe ich gehört, habe ich gehört. Kaufst dir einen WLAN-Router, äh rauchst dir ein WLAN, Excesspoint, der weltweit vertrieben wird äh und den Clemens zum Beispiel sehr gerne empfiehlt. Und ähm,
machst den an und ähm.
Kann's dann zum Beispiel einstellen, dass du dich in einem anderen Land befindest? Ähm zum Beispiel nicht in Deutschland, dann stellt er dir unter Umständen eben auch andere Kanäle zur Verfügung und andere Sendeleistungen, ja? Äh,
da kannste dann meistens mal nochmal so ein halbes Watt oder ein Watt mehr äh auf die Antenne geben, äh weil die äh Geräte eben
für den europäischen Markt anders konfiguriert werden als für den äh US-Markt. Ähm anders äh oder noch spannender ist das auch mit mit allgemeinen Funkgeräten, die du häufig äh,
wenn die Idee jetzt so ein CB-Funkgerät kaufst vom äh vom Hersteller wie äh Midland oder so, dann kannst du da ein paar LÖtbrücken ändern und schon hast du irgendwie.
Statt irgendwie vierzig äh oder achtzig Kanälen halt vierhundert, weil das Ding eben äh über und unter dem CB Spektrum eben auch nochmal ganz gut äh funken kann. Ähm.
Und solche Sachen wollen sie jetzt halt irgendwie unterbinden.
Im im WLAN-Bereich sieht man da jetzt, glaube ich, eigentlich wenig äh.
Luder, der es jetzt irgendwie stören könnte, so im äh in dem Mobilfunkbereich hatte ich das, glaube ich, aber auch schon mal erwähnt, äh dass der gesamte Teil der quasi die.
Den Funk steuert. Ja, also das, was dein Mobiltelefon wirklich am Ende auf die Antenne gibt.
Und zwar auf Ebene GSM, UMTSLTE. Ähm das wird gesteuert von einem sogar eigenen Prozessor, dem ähm.
Baseband Processer, denn auch vom anderen Hersteller kommt ähm und wo große Maßnahmen bestehen.
Insbesondere einfach, dass das ganze dass die Baseband eben ein ein binärer Block ist, den du niemals äh verstehen wirst, äh damit du eben nicht,
mit dem Telefon auf einmal irgendwas anderes machen kannst, ja? Zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, äh nicht
korrekte Nachrichten an das Mobilfunknetz senden äh und dieses dadurch irgendwie zur Instabilität bringen, ne, oder solche oder zu viele Nachrichten senden oder so. Das heißt, man versucht da sehr klar zu trennen zwischen dem
Betriebssystem des Telefones und dem Betriebssystem der der Funkschnittstelle, ja? Und äh.
Bei WLAN-Rutern und so äh ist ist die eine derartig strenge Trennung äh nicht nicht unbedingt da,
denn da gibt's dann halt irgendwie einen Treiber und das äh das WLAN Interface ist dann irgendwie da. Und.
Interessanterweise ist es aber so, dass du ohnehin seit äh seit langer Zeit ähm im WLAN-Bereich.
So Systems on the Chipers. Das heißt, nur das Absichern der äh Fond Funk-Firmware wird irgendwie nix, weil das eben alles ein ein Klumpen-Linux ist. Und ähm,
Da wollen sie jetzt irgendwie halt dafür sorgen, dass sichergestellt ist, dass die Geräte konform bleiben. Äh um jetzt nochmal auf die Eingangsgeschichte äh zurückzukommen, ähm,
dass es ein, dass das einen legitimen äh Zweck hat ähm und diesen Zweck zumindest fördern sollte ähm.
Aber und erforderlich sein muss im Sinne von es gibt keinen anderen kein anderes Ziel zum Zweck, das ist alles gegeben, aber das Problem ist, es gibt einfach es gibt einfach kein Problem mit der,
unkonfigurierung von WLAN Geräten oder anderen Funkgeräten in diesem Land, was irgendwie nennenswert wäre, ganz im Gegenteil, Funkamateure sind ja darauf angewiesen, dass sie das ARD auch machen können
Ja, also äh die können halt entweder äh äh regelkonforme Hardware kaufen und umbauen im Rahmen ihrer äh.
Im Rahmen ihrer Tätigkeit als Funkamateure ähm oder äh irgendwie versuchen, das selber zu bauen, ja? Und das geht eben natürlich auch gar nicht. Ähm.
Und insofern ist das hier äh sehr, sehr.
Gefährlich, was sie da machen, weil das Problem, das irgendwie hier nicht regelkonform funkende
WLAN, Hardware oder so irgendwelche Probleme verursachen würde, das gibt's eben nicht. Das gibt's einfach nicht. Und äh insofern gibt's hier auch wenig Anlass, das zu lösen,
in der Präambel dieser EU Verordnung EU-Richtlinie.
Steht in Artikel drei Abschnitt eins. Ausdrücklich sogar, dass die Funkanlage sicherstellen muss,
Entschuldigung, der EU in der Präambel steht. Die Sperre darf nicht dazu missbraucht werden.
Die Verwendung der Anlagen mit Software von unabhängigen Anbietern zu verhindern. Ähm.
Aber das wird nix bringen, weil du kannst irgendwie grade bei diesen Systems on the Chip nicht sagen, ja ähm.
Du kannst du hast eine saubere Trennung zwischen irgendwie Funkrelevanten Teilen und anderen Systemrelevanten teilen,
und diesen Nachweis wird eben auch kein
Hersteller erbringen wollen, dass er sagt, ja ja, wir haben ja äh man kann halt ein anderes Betriebssystem drauf flashen, aber den Treiber, den Wählern Treiber muss man von uns als Block kriegen. Äh insofern haben wir unsere, unserer Pflicht, äh unserer
unsere Pflicht erfüllt. Ähm sondern im Gegenteil, die Hersteller werden halt jetzt rechtlich dazu gezwungen.
Um Rechtssicherheit zu haben möglichst ihren
prozess halt irgendwie zu verrangeln ähm und irgendwie so eine Art äh oder sonst was auf WLAN-Routern zu machen, damit da bloß keiner irgendwas dran verändert, damit das Ding nicht nachher in irgendeiner Form
theoretisch zweckentfremdet oder außerhalb seiner Spezifikation genutzt werden könnte, was eben ohnehin kaum jemanden macht, außer,
zum Beispiel die ganze Freifunk-Community, die,
das eigens entwickelte Meshprotokoll eben auf WLAN redet und dafür natürlich darauf angewiesen ist,
sind enorme Veränderungen ähm an diesen Geräten auf der Softwareseite vorzunehmen. Ähm nämlich.
In der Regel eben Open-WRT auf die Geräte zu spielen. Ähm und äh dann eben dieses Routing zu machen, was für was eben der Kern äh von Freifung ist und da die die absolute äh Magie,
ist die, die dieses, die diese Community und dieses Netz ausmacht, äh die wir unter keinen Umständen verlieren dürfen.
Und wie gesagt, auf der anderen Seite geht's eben gar kein äh Problem, was jetzt hier ähm gelöst wurde. Ganz im Gegenteil äh lese ich auch, dass zum Beispiel ähm,
D-WRT, das äh Projekt, was Tim grade schon äh angesprochen hat, ähm.
Mit den äh Geräteherstellern zusammenarbeitet, die kriegen dann halt äh,
den letzten Wifi Treiber als Blob dazu und können den in ihre in ihre sonstige Open Source Geschichte da reinknoten. Ähm
Ebenfalls arbeitet äh Blopp, Beine wie Blopp, also binärer Treiber, der dann eben als,
Fertiges ähm Modul dann eben nur noch eingebunden wird und nicht von denen jetzt äh signifikant umgeschrieben werden kann von den äh DDWRT Leuten. Also es ist im Prinzip schon in der Zusammenarbeit heute ähm.
Ähm Realität, dass das so stattfindet. Aber man findet eben dann in den Anweisungen, wo dann,
in der in der FCC-Regulation
quasi sogar den Satz beschreiben sie im Detail, wie das Gerät gegen Flashen und die Installation von Drittanbieter wie DDWRT geschützt ist. Und das ist eigentlich natürlich das letzte äh was du möchtest. Das äh,
dass das verhindert wird, auch aus einer äh aus einer wirtschaftlichen äh Perspektive.
Und das ist wirklich schlecht. Ähm,
Äh genau, also das waren die F, was ich gerade zitiert habe, das waren die ähm FCC äh Anweisungen für Geräte, Hersteller und Importeure,
Man muss dann direkt sagen, man für die FC quasi nimmt direkt auf auf DDWT Bezug und sagt, wie wird verhindert, dass das gemacht.
Und ähm das ist natürlich äh sehr, sehr schlecht.
Partys from Loading non US Versions of the Softwarefirma on the Device, das ist,
vom Flashing.
Da ist die Frage, ob die ist, damit wirklich, wirklich einen Schutz äh äh herbeiführen letztlich, wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe, äh bietet das letztlich alles gar keinen Schutz.
Nicht ähm.
Also nicht gegen das Fehlverhalten, ne.
Nicht wirklich.
Ich ich sehe irgendwie kein, ich sehe keinen nennenswerten Schutz. Ich sehe vor allem kein Problem durch die Funktionserweiterung von äh insbesondere wir sprechen jetzt hier viel über WLAN, weil das natürlich äh sehr relevant ist, aber ich meine, äh wir wir haben gerade an
an äh an alle Leute irgendwie beim Camp äh dieses großartige Radio ähm verteilt.
Dass ein Großteil nicht alle, aber ein Großteil der Funkfunktionen.
Äh des alltäglichen Lebens äh problemlos wieder implementieren kann, ja? Und dann kannst du alles drauf machen. Mit mit einigen Einschränkungen, wo wir jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen muss, aber nicht, dass jetzt nachher äh die Amateurfunker mir hier Mail schreiben. Ähm.
Du meinst die Leute dürfen da Drittanbieter Software drauf installieren? Das ist ja ein Skandal.
Das Ding
da gibt's keine Erstanbieter-Software für, dass man da also es gibt eine es gibt eine sehr rudimentäre, ne? Das ist ja die Hack AF äh äh die da teilweise draufläuft mit einigen Modifikationen und so. Ähm.
Aber da wird jetzt halt äh zu Leibe gerückt und ich glaube, dass das insbesondere in diesem WLAN-Bereich halt echt Mist ist so.
Also das wird auch Scheiße für für so Hersteller wie Peeling und so, ne, die ihr die werden ja hauptsächlich gekauft, weil man da halt dann mit Open WRT vernünftige äh Firmenway drauf hat. Du willst ja sowas nicht irgendwie äh
ernsthaft betreiben, was die dir da ausliefern.
Ja, es ist wirklich ein bisschen dreckig. Aber denkst du, dass das für die auch ein signifikanter Markt ist? Also, ernsthaft?
Ne, es,
Ich weiß nicht, ob das für die ein signifikanter Markt ist, aber von deren Codequalität her zu urteilen, wird es für die ein signifikantes Problem dafür zu sorgen, dass sie, dass man da keine andere Firmen mehr drauf flashen kann,
weil das ist nicht so einfach getan. Also im Prinzip Artikel wird dann hier gesprochen von äh ähm.
Von äh DRM äh,
Aber das äh digital. Äh das heißt, dass das halt irgendwie was weiß ich, der du so was machst, wie dass der WLAN-Chip, wenn ihm zum Beispiel gesagt wird, hallo, ähm.
Benutze doch mal Kanal dreizehn, ja, dass er dann sagt, ah, bist du überhaupt eine
die berechtigt ist, mir eine derartige Anweisung zu geben. Also so müsste letztendlich das Security-Konzept dafür aussehen,
weil der WLAN-Chip kann ja sowieso immer alles und ihm wird dann halt, wenn wir jetzt von sende mal mit höherer Leistung oder so sprechen, dann wird dem Chip halt von
irgendwas, was Körnle äh oder was halt,
Firmenwert des Gerätes ist, wird ihm dann gesagt, ey, übrigens, heute mal Funken mit der Sendestärke. Und dann müsste der der WLAN.
Teil des Gerätes sicher versichern lassen, dass das, was ihm grade da diesen Befehl gibt,
dazu ermächtigt ist ihm überhaupt.
Ja, das ist das ist unmöglich.
Ne? Und das hast du bei dieser, bei dieser Treiber-Kommunikation nicht wirklich,
dass du sagst, hey, bist du denn wirklich das Betriebssystem? Also und das kannst du halt nicht äh also das wird schwere, schwierig. Und die einfachste Lösung ist natürlich zu sagen, ja wunderbar, dann ähm.
Machen wir halt ab jetzt nun, machen wir halt irgendeine Form von ähm Signaturprüfung auf die Updates.
Und wir installieren immer nur signierte Fears und ähm.
Dann äh und signierte sonstige Updates auf unsere Systems, Office,
und dann ist gut, ja? Und dann hast du natürlich das Problem, dass dass der, dass die.
Hersteller in der Regel überhaupt gar kein Interesse haben, die Geräte bis bis in alle Ewigkeit zu unterstützen. Hass ja selbst bei.
Den alten Apple iPhones, ne? Ist jetzt mal ein gutes Beispiel. Da treten dann von mir aus Sicherheitslücken auf, aber äh die werden dann halt teilweise noch nicht mal mehr gefixt.
Und ähm.
Also du hast das du hast das du hast die Security Probleme, dass ähm die Wenders teilweise Sachen nicht fixen und die Drittanbieter Software besser ist, sonst gäbe es ja nicht,
Ja, also es gäbe ja kein äh keine Marktnische für Drittanbieter Software, wenn die Herstellersoftware äh.
Gut wäre, ja, dann dann würde sich ja nicht eine Marktnische für eine Drittanbieter Software ergeben. Und
Offenbar gibt es dann auch eben einige Hersteller, Gerätehersteller, die sogar sagen, super. Das ist bei uns sogar Drittanbieter Software gibt, die von einer lebendigen Community gepflegt wird. Das nehmen wir einfach mal als äh,
als positiven positives Extra, was wir halt noch mit äh für Interessierte Nutzer in unser Marketing nehmen können. Und da pflegen wir so eine Community. Ja, wunderbar. Und dann hast du eine, so und dann werden jetzt da eben die diesen,
Geräte.
Herstellern plötzlich äh Regulationen auf den Tisch gelegt, wo gesagt wird, ey Freunde, hier äh Ruhe, da müsst ihr jetzt mal für für Zucht und Ordnung sorgen. So.
Das halte ich für da sehe ich, ich sehe nirgendwo den den Grund, weil wo da jetzt wo da irgendjemand was von hätte. Das ist einfach von vorne bis hinten nicht gut.
Ja gut, ich meine, man geht halt davon aus, dass äh sozusagen die original äh äh Software zumindest äh äh sich halbwegs richtig äh verhält und man damit dann eben keine Probleme erzeugt hier mit dem Funkverkehr von Flugzeugen et cetera.
Und das äh man man versucht dann diesen Status quo äh zu erhalten, indem man sagt, okay Firmenway, nur wenn sie signiert ist. Ich meine, das
natürlich dann sich leicht knacken lassen wird, ist äh äh offenbar, ich meine sogar die iPhones äh werden immer wieder aufgemacht und da steckt schon ein erhebliches Know-How und ein großes Eigeninteresse von Apple dahinter, das Ding auch wirklich dicht zu machen
und wenn ihr das eigene Interesse bei den Herstellern hier schon von vorne rein so reduziert ist, wird das natürlich alles nicht sehr viel bringen.
Nee. Aber unschön ist es allemal. Also ich finde das immer äh ich finde das jetzt,
ungünstig, sich darauf zu sich jetzt darauf zu berufen, zu sagen, hach, das habt ihr noch nie hingekriegt, dass äh dass wir eure Geräte nicht irgendwie noch mal mit alternativen Firmenwares flachen, das kriegt ihr auch jetzt nicht hin.
Nee, also das wollte ich jetzt auch damit nicht sagen. Das ist natürlich auch ein Problem, dass man sich halt potenziell irgendwie strafbar äh macht oder zumindest irgendwelche anderen Vergehen schuldig macht und das ist natürlich gerade Organisation, auch davon äh abhalten könnte jetzt so mit Open-WRT, die DWRT oder was auch immer für eine Firma die Ployten
Geräte überhaupt Netzwerke aufzubauen, weil sie dann sagen, uh, nee, da setzen wir uns dann irgendwie in die Nesseln und das ist natürlich ein großes Problem. Dementsprechend müsste man halt gegen diese Richtlinie vorgehen. Das Problem ist halt nur, dass diese Richtlinie bereits beschlossen ist und es halt einfach
keiner äh wohl gemerkt hat, dass es diese Richtlinie überhaupt gibt, beziehungsweise, dass da sowas drin steht, was man äh eigentlich gar nicht will.
Das ist bitterer Scheiß, ja. Also da haben unsere Frühwarnsysteme versagt, denn ich würde jetzt in dem Fall sogar echt sagen.
Äh wenn da jetzt zum richtigen Zeitpunkt mal irgendwo eine eine kompetente Auskunftsperson angehört worden wäre, wäre es ihr vielleicht echt gelungen
zu erklären, dass man da den den Markt vielleicht besser auf eine andere Weise harmonetarisiert so und das
das ist äh sehr schlecht so. Ich meine, wir können jetzt hoffen, dass die dass die FCC da jetzt halt draufkloppt
die FCC. Äh die IFF da jetzt draufkloppt und wenigstens verhindert, dass die FCC sowas erlässt?
Und wenn die äh wenn das sich wenn das dann nur so ein EU-Ding ist, dann können wir halt wirklich darauf hoffen, dass das dass das einfach ein.
Nicht beachtet wird.
Und dann können wir auch darauf hoffen, dass sich da niemals irgendwo ein ein Kläger oder ein Richter finden werden, dazu vorsichtig gesprochen
aber der Oberwitz ist ja, ne, Richtlinie heißt, wird ja dann auch noch von den ganzen EU-Staaten umgesetzt werden müssen und dann hast du,
in den ähm in den ganzen EU-Staaten eigens formulierte Gesetze, die irgendwie darauf Bezug nehmen wollen,
und für die für für einen Anbieter, der auf dem deutschen Markt vertreten sein will, heißt das dann, dass er ja im Prinzip,
Die ganzen Einzelgesetze erfüllen muss, also die restriktivste Auslegung der Kombination aller.
Ja und da gibt's bestimmt immer ein paar Länder, die da sehr restriktiv sein wollen.
Ja, also das ist echt ein, das ist wirklich äh kacke. Da fällt mir jetzt auch wenig zu ein, außer äh kauft, was es zu kaufen gibt, solange diese Richtlinien nicht in Kraft ist, so äh das brauchen wir nachher.
Gut, muss man.
Also gerade Freifunk ist damit irgendwie massiv
bedroht, ne? Wenn das äh wenn da irgendwie mal in ein paar Jahren ernsthaft Nägel mit Köpfen gemacht wird, denn dann säßen die ganzen Freifunnker da und müssten irgendwie alte Geräte äh reparieren. Oder wir müssten halt irgendwie,
da irgendwie so versuchen so Wettkämpfe zu zu veranstalten. Ich meine ein paar paar Runden von ähm,
Updates und Secure Boots geh versuchen, von so ein paar Herstellern äh wirst du schon überleben, aber da das da viele von diesen Geräten einfach,
arm sind, also äh Armprozessoren
hast du da auch unter Umständen ganz gute äh Vorarbeit schon auf der Ebene und dann kriegen die das auch hin.
Ja
Wo ist halt denn jetzt mal überhaupt erst mal schauen ähm inwiefern sich da noch irgendwas äh machen lässt oder inwiefern sich da sozusagen für das Problem überhaupt Aufmerksamkeit
erzielen lässt und welche äh Angebote man machen kann, weil dieses
gefühlte Problem ist ja dann immer noch im Raum, dass das sozusagen alles schwierig ist und dass Software sich ja falsch verhalten kann et cetera, das
Ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch zu verstehen, auch wenn die Konsequenz jetzt falsch ist, also dass man nicht einfach alles irgendwie beliebig äh in die Wolken strahlen lassen will, weil man sieht ja
das auch kaputt machen kann potenziell, also man könnte ein GSM-Netzwerk eben durch Rogue-Telefone ganz gut aushebeln und das ist natürlich dann äh auch bei anderen kritischen Systemen der Fall.
Und.
Da wäre zu überlegen, wie man, was man da für Angebote machen kann.
Also bei, wie gesagt, bei Mobiltelefon ist das sowieso so. Gut, da ist das Ganze nochmal irgendwie viel,
viel äh radikaler getrennt, aber du kriegst nicht ohne Weiteres ein modernes Smartphone dazu, irgendein Funksignal zu senden, wat nicht standardkonform ist. Dafür ist da das Basewind drin. Gibt's irgendwie
alte diese ganze Osmom-Bewegung natürlich, ne, wo du irgendwie alte Motorola-Geräte mit mit Custom Basebands versehen kannst und so, da kann man dann irgendwie mal drüber reden. Aber so grundsätzlich ist das Immobilientelefonbereich
geklärt. Und eine ähnliche,
äh Trennung, ja? Der Vergleich hinkt an vielen Stellen, aber eine ähnliche technische Trennung hast du ja eben durch ähm durch Treiber und ähm.
Den das restliche Betriebssystem, ja? Und ähm.
Da ist es ja heute schon so, dass das jetzt die diese ganzen Open-Source-Community keine ähm Änderungen oder an vielen Treibern eben keine, keine konkreten Änderungen vornehmen oder vornehmen müssen. Und,
Ich stecke auch jetzt in Freifunk nicht tief genug drin, um zu wissen, wie weit die da äh rumfuchteln. Ähm aber es ist.
Einfach, also es ist einfach, es gibt halt grade kein Problem, die Geräte funken doch alle konform. Weißt du, also.
Ich sehe da keinen Bedarf. Also wie gesagt, ich sehe kein Problem, kein kein ernsthaftes Problem, was dadurch gelöst wird und viele neue, die dadurch geschaffen werden. Und
Ich hoffe, dass man einfach erklärt bekommt, so dass wie die wie es halt heute in den meisten Fällen ist. Ähm,
dass das einfach so wie es heute ist in Ordnung ist und damit auch unter diese Regulation fällt, der Hersteller sorgt dafür, dass da nicht äh nicht ohne Weiteres äh das Ding außer Rand und Band ist.
Ja, ist die Frage, wer wer der Hersteller ist, ne? Und ähm
Also wer als Hersteller äh gilt, ähm es gab wohl auch Fälle, wo sich Freifunkgeräte nicht richtig verhalten haben.
Das wurde dann moniert, das wurde auch behoben, also zumindest in den betroffenen Fällen, kann er sich jetzt im Einzelnen nicht aufzählen, so habe ich das aber gehört, müsste man nochmal ein bisschen nachfragen. Ähm grundsätzlich gibt's natürlich schon dieses
Problem, dass eben äh ein Wildwuchs äh Verhaltenswildwuchs da eingeschränkt werden muss. Und da muss man gegebenenfalls mal mit kreativen Ideen aufkommen, wie man dem begegnen kann.
Ja, absolut, es ist ein absolutes Desaster.
Okay, ähm wir haben jetzt, wir wurden dann jetzt doch von den äh Aufnahmeproblemen eingeholt und können jetzt nicht mehr wirklich äh miteinander kommunizieren, deswegen.
Äh führen wir die äh Debatte gegebenenfalls in der nächsten Woche,
Weiter, wenn wir hören, was wir beide jeweils gesagt haben, ob's noch was zu sagen ist. Und ich bringe die Sendung jetzt mal kurz hier äh mehr oder weniger alleine zum Abschluss.
Und zwar wollte ich abschließend noch die Initiative Stopp Büb bewerben, äh die betrifft,
unsere äh schweizer Hörer und Hörerinnen.
Dazu hatte der ausführlich in Lokbuch Netzpolitik einhundertundzwei nur weniger Admins haben Zugriff berichtet und da gibt es jetzt ein Referendum zu dem
anstehenden Nachrichtendienstgesetz,
und ähm da möchten wir natürlich alle äh Hörer und Hörerinnen aus der Schweiz aufrufen ähm dieses Referendum zu unterstützen.
Ähm nein zum Überwachungsstaat ist der Titel. Ähm es wurden jetzt schon äh ich glaube fünfzehntausend äh,
Unterschriften gesammelt. Aber um das äh Überwachungsgesetz Büff und das Nachrichtendienstgesetz NDG äh zu verhindern, ähm braucht man äh bis zum sechsten A,
Oktober, nee, ab dem sechsten Oktober innerhalb von drei Monaten,
fünfzigtausend Unterschriften und sie haben jetzt ein äh Formular online gestellt unter Nachrichtendienstgesetz Punkt CH
wo man sich anmelden, wo man sich melden kann, wenn man mithelfen kann, Unterschriften zu sammeln. Und
wirst dann oder wer das macht, wird dann mit mit einem Argumentarium, mit Tick, Tipps und Tricks und äh den Referendumsbögen ähm versorgt.
Und äh man kann dann also irgendwie sagen so, ich sammle so und so viele Unterschriften, man soll so ungefähr zehn bis zwanzig pro Stunde äh bei seinen Berechnungen zu Grunde legen und ähm.
Dann kann man sich also daran äh beteiligen, gibt irgendwie Name, E-Mail an und äh kann eben dann dazu.
Ähm dafür Sorge tragen, äh dass mit Hilfe eines Referendums eben dann hoffentlich das Nachrichtendienstgesetz und das ähm zu Fall kommen,
dafür sei hiermit äh geworden,
und ähm ich glaube, dass äh Deutsche ähm bei Schweizer Referenten ähm
diskriminiert werden und nicht äh mitmachen dürfen. Aber sollte das falsch sein, weil diese das steht hier nicht bei äh auf der Seite oder ich konnte das nicht schnell genug auf der Bündnisseite finden.
Sollte das falsch sein, korrigiere ich das in der nächsten Sendung. Und äh natürlich werden wir dann auch zusehen, dass wir den Tiere bald nochmal.
Bei uns einladen. Dann wollte ich ja, habe ich ja gesagt, noch mal kurz auf den elften Geburtstag von Netz Politik ORG Bezug nehmen. Das war eine schöne Veranstaltung, wirklich fein. Mit einer Reihe an Kurzvorträgen. Ähm.
Die ich ans Herz lege, die äh auch verlinkt sind. Ähm in den,
Nee, das kann ich, ich will, wir werden sie hoffentlich verlinken, wenn sie dann online sind. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob sie schon online sind, gab's auf jeden Fall äh spannende Vorträge natürlich von Markus und Andre, ähm Klaus Landefeld und äh ganz vielen anderen, die ich jetzt,
gar nicht äh so namentlich erwähnen möchte, weil ich müsste eigentlich alle erwähnen, das war ein sehr schöne Veranstaltung und ähm.
Besonders schön war natürlich die äh Party im Anschluss
über die nicht berichtet werden darf, aber man kann den man kann der öffentlichen Ankündigung, glaube ich, entnehmen
dass da äh Stil und Bense gespielt haben mit äh großartigen, einem großartigen Auftritt. Ähm das ist die Kombo von
Arne Benze, der ja auch hier das ähm.
Cyber, Cyber in der originalen und in der Akustikversion äh hervorgebracht hat.
Und ähm leider gibt's keine Aufzeichnung von dem Set, aber es gibt einen Soundcloud-Account mit äh mit deren äh Songs und äh,
von ihren Auftritten, den wollte ich auch nochmal empfehlen, weil der echt cool ist.
Und dann bleibt mir nur noch zu danken, nämlich dem Christian, dem Georg, dem Benedikt und dem Dirk. Tschau, tschau.